meal replacement
shakes a fat activist latest fight
America's hallways are too tight yeah
plus-size influencer named jayen Cheney
says hotels need to make their hallways
bigger to accommodate obese people it's
one of many recommendations she posted
to to improve accessibility watch I'm on
a mission to revolutionize the travel
industry and make it a more accessible
accepting accommodating place for all
provide sturdy wider chairs without
armrest sure beds with strong support
and a higher weight capacity make
elevators and hallways spacious to allow
for easy movement of larger individuals
and those utilizing Mobility devices
offer adjustable handheld shower heads
and raise toilet seats for added
accessibility offer larger beach and
pool seating provide size inclusive
bathrobes display clear and accurate
information on these amenities on hotel
websites I like all of that and I'm not
fat but it appears that while it's
offensive to expect her to change her
lifestyle it's imperative that all of us
change ours well has it worked so far
the only venue willing to accommodate
her is
SeaWorld
so
cat
cat um you have a weight problem we've
been talking about it um I knew you were
going to go to me first I'm definitely
the person the overweight Community
wants to hear from the most no the I
think the overweight Community would be
disgusted by this I I think and I I
think I speak for them a few times a
year I'm overweight
she finds it she would find it offensive
if people told her to lose weight but
she's perfectly fine to have an entire
society change for her well she's like
we matter her just as everybody else
it's like okay but you seem to not
understand that yeah you seem to think
you're the most important because the
way she my favorite right was when she
said just widen in the hallways yeah
that's impossible well no because here's
the thing hallways are attached to
ceilings and Floors right so you can't
widen them at least without causing a
mass casualty event yeah it's true it's
true you have to actually have to widen
the buildings he's like I'm asking you
to make some simple accommodations like
please demolish the building and rebuild
it she thinks it's she thinks to en to
enlarge a building is as easy as like
just eating and eating and enlarging
yourself there's plenty of things I
would like you know like all clothing to
have sleeves because my arms are very
like is she okay looking and sometimes
sometimes I still like the out and I
just go for it and then the arms are out
there I'm not going to demand all
clothes has sleeves just cuz my arms are
disgusting this is a great Point uh uh
what's your name again Joe Joe so I'm a
I'm basically a gorob I have a fear of
open spaces and I'm a person of small
stature shouldn't I demand smaller rooms
and narrower hallways to make me feel
better Joe no Greg because that would be
entitled and it made me think that maybe
at one point in the past
she was thin and beautiful to have
developed such an entitled personality
like
that but I also wrote some other on
liners which I think you'll
enjoy gather around Greg I'm guessing
Comfort sweets isn't just her favorite
Hotel surprisingly surprisingly she
didn't mention increasing the size of
the fitness
center up
there you
know H sometimes it's just a relief to
have a comedian
prepare that's unfair he wrote in
advance that's
unfair David where do you stand on this
I mean we're this is not about obese
people this is about somebody who feels
entitled that Society should change for
her look when I talk about hotels MH
item number one yeah
breakfast can we get it past 7:30 in the
morning you know she didn't even mention
that yeah yeah it's like you're on
vacation you're having the time in your
life and it's like oh you got to get up
you got to be down here between 5: and 7
yeah if you want a box of uh Frosted
Flakes yeah I mean what about my rights
I sleep I am out all night mm I need to
wake up at the crack of noon mhm and go
get a continent
yeah do you know what else bothers me
you know check in 1:00 but check outs at
11: like we lose two hours on that on
that tradeoff exactly you don't even get
24 hours out of your hotel stay no
that's wrong I should get a refund yeah
it's like you have to call for a late
checkout and then they act like they're
doing you a favor we got to what we got
to do is find these criminals and figure
have them figure out how we can steal
hotel rooms I know how to do that you
just cross the border yeah yeah you just
cross the border yeah there you go
there's your answer wow they had it
everything's all worked out well um she
she's criticizing all these industries
what do you think is next on her list I
mean she this could apply to every
building on earth well this chick better
never go to Europe because they don't
even give skinning people a full shower
door there yeah or two towels or air
conditioning or water so just don't go
there but honestly half the country is
over overweight obese so maybe it's a
good business model to start building
these spaces I don't know I don't know
maybe there's a market for it I the the
Obesity numbers are very interesting
because sometimes they're very large
yeah but no but they're also they're
deceptive like when you look at bmis
it's like everybody's obese compared to
the BMI what's that called body mass
body mass index don't look at that just
go to the county fair yeah I count I
count as obese because of how heavy my
muscles are uh but can we make one more
point about the continental breakfast
while we're complaining about that
usually they only have a 3-hour range
which makes it hard to go twice
yeah and what is so Continental about it
what's up with that what's up with the
Continental I don't get
it oh was so
silent I I don't know I mean you're
right what is a continent yeah you know
you go there there's no continents no
there's none there's no reference to
plate tectonics anywhere not one what's
the difference between a continental and
an American breakfast M well American
breakfast you'll have eggs Continental
you might not have eggs it's just you
know we do a Fox Nation special on
continental breakfast hosted by cat
Tim I wouldn't say
no all right we got to move on coming up
in local news kittens drivers and emu
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else